Welcome.
Thank you for joining me on this
exploration of the Silver
Reed LK150 Knitting Machine.
This is a fun, versatile machine that many
knitters use, and you may have
been curious about it as well.
Follow along with me,
and we'll talk about why it's so popular
and what you can do with this machine.
Now, before we go any further,
I want to remind you
that Knit It Now has a Glossary.
You may hear me use some terms
today that you're not familiar with.
Go to the Glossary,
it's go to >learn and then down
to >Glossary, and there's an alphabetical
listing and also a visual listing of terms
and words that are used specifically with
machine knitting and knitting in general.
So if you hear something and you go,
What in the world is she talking about?
Go to the Glossary
and you'll get a definition.
Why is this machine so popular?
I believe one of the first
reasons is that it's lightweight.
It is a plastic bed machine,
which makes it lightweight,
and you can carry it around easily.
You can take it up and down
without hurting your back.
Many knitters will take
it when they travel.
Maybe take it in your RV.
You can also put it in maybe a shotgun
case and take it on an airplane.
I've been known to do that,
to take it to a hotel room and then
clamp it to the vanity in a bathroom.
And voila, I've got a knitting station.
Good lighting and nobody can bother me,
and I can do some knitting
while I'm on the road.
It's durable.
It's made with a durable plastic
that can last a long, long time.
Its needles have little
ball bearings on the top.
If you notice here in the image,
the pink there are these little ball
bearing caps on the needle bed,
on the needle butt,
and it makes it easier to push
the carriage back and forth,
so it's easy to use.
Another nice thing about this
machine is it is expandable.
You can expand it to 200, to 250,
to 300 needles if you want.
As long as you have a table wide enough
to support it,
you can knit wider pieces with it.
Another big reason that this machine is
popular is it's a great way to get
started in machine knitting.
It's reasonably priced,
and many knitters start here and then
quickly realize that they
want a little bit more.
But for For now, let's have
some fun with the LK150.
Now, my partner Matt recently asked me,
if somebody already owns a knitting
machine, why would they
want to buy this one?
Well, there's a couple of reasons.
First off, it's a mid gage machine, 6.
5 millimeters between the needles,
which means that it's going to take...
It's going to use a wide variety of yarns,
everything from a sock weight all the way
up to a light worsted weight yarn,
decay, fingering, everything in between.
So it takes a nice wide range of yarn.
A lot of knitters start with a
standard gage machine, 4.
5 millimeters.
Takes thinner yarn, maybe lace weight,
even stock weight
and a lot smaller stitches.
So a lot of knitters like to go to the mid
gage because they can use a wider variety
of yarns, a lot of the hand-knitting yarns
that you can buy in any yarn store,
and the stitches are bigger and they're
easy easier to see and manipulate.
As I mentioned before,
a lot of knitters like to travel
with their machines, just like me.
And this one's lightweight.
You can put it in your motorhome.
One of the biggest features,
I think, is that it's easy to learn.
There are really only four things
that you need to know about this machine.
They're not a whole lot
of buttons and levers.
The manual is actually thin because it's
very, very simple to learn this machine.
And another reason that someone
who already has a machine would want this
LK150 is that you can
quickly use up your stash.
Or if you're a brand new knitter,
maybe you're a hand knitter and you've got
this huge stash of yarn
that you want to use up.
The LK150 is quick and easy to learn.
Throw some yarn at it and you can make
blankets and scarves
and hats and whatever.
Learn to do those really, really quickly.
As with any knitting machine,
you can knit quickly.
And if you've had any experience with
knitting machines, just think about this.
You started out as a hand knitter and you
laboriously knit one stitch at a time.
But think about knitting 150
stitches with one pass of the carriage.
It goes so quickly,
and you can get things done.
Now, can you do absolutely Really
everything on a knitting machine?
No.
And should you try?
In my opinion, no.
My motto has always been,
do the boring stuff by machine and do
the hard stuff or the fun stuff by hand.
A really good example of that are these
round neck, round yoke sweaters
that are so popular right now.
Can you knit one of those round yoke
sweaters on the knitting machine?
Well, sure.
I personally wouldn't.
Knit, pick up your hand knitting needles,
knit that round yoke sweater in the round
with all the colors and all the stranded
knitting and everything
else that you want.
And then when you've got the hard stuff
done or the fun stuff done,
pick up those stitches and knit the boring
sleeve, stockinette sleeves and the boring
stockinette bodies by machine,
and you can be done in no time.
I mentioned the word versatile before.
Another advantage of this machine is that,
again, it takes a wide variety of yarns.
So you might have a lot
of yarns in your stash.
It's great.
You can't use them all on a
standard gage machine.
But on this mid gage,
you can choose whatever yarn you
want and knit it however you want.
So I mentioned that there were four things
that you really need
to know to use this machine.
There's only four things.
Now, compared to this pass-up machine
that I just got, oh, my gosh, there's
a zillion things to learn on that machine.
On the LK, there's just really
four things that you need to know.
The first one is the tension dial,
the relation of this tension dial
and the numbers on the tension dial
to the stitch size that you're
going to be knitting.
I had quite a long discussion at one time
with a knitter who insisted that these
numbers on this tension dial
equalled hand knitting needles.
Well, number one, if you're thinking hand
knitting needles in millimeters or hand
knitting needles in US sizes,
there's a difference.
Number two, I may pick up a size five
needle and knit at a specific gage.
You may pick up a size five needle
in the same yarn, and your gage is
going to be completely different.
And I guarantee you that a size,
a number five on the LK150 is going
to be even different from that.
So no, these numbers do not correspond
with hand knitting needle sizes.
However, However, it might be a good way
for you to knit your
get-acquainted swatch.
A get-acquainted swatch is to take a brand
new yarn that you may have purchased,
put it on the machine,
cast on at a starting tension,
and then a little bit,
and feel it and see what you think.
And then maybe change the tension
by a full number and feel it and see what
you think, and do that up and down
the scale from 2 to 5 or 5 to 7, whatever.
So if the ball of the yarn that you
purchased suggests a size 5 US needle,
you might start with a five
on your tension dial.
It's just a good starting place for where
to start to establish what your gage is.
So the second thing that you need to know
and really understand
are the needle positions.
This is what controls patterns and stitch
patterning and how your
machine actually works.
So if you don't remember anything else
about today, please Please really
pay attention to needle positions.
There are little number indicators
on the left-hand side of any machine.
This is not just the LK150.
Any machine is going to have A, B, C,
and D, or A, B, D, and E,
or E, and F, or Q, and Z.
I don't care what the letter is.
It's the positions that make a difference
as to how the machine operates.
If your needles, you see the pink needles
at the top right there are all the way
back, those are in A position
or out-of-work position.
That means nothing's going to happen when
you're knitting with
the needles in that position.
I'll show you what happens underneath
the machine in just a second,
but stick with me.
The second position would be your B
position, which would be
your working position.
So when you're knitting,
if needles are in this position,
they're going to go through the track
underneath that carriage and
be moved into position for them
to pick up yarn and form stitches.
So working position is forming stitches.
The C position is middle position,
and this is used when you are paterning.
And those needles
that are in that C position are going
to go through a different track underneath
your carriage and do something else,
depending on how your carriage is set.
And then D position is all the way out.
This would be your hold position or
on this machine, your tuck position.
Needles will not knit.
So you would use this
for short row shaping.
You would use this for bridging.
So these four needle
positions are very important.
I mentioned the tracks
underneath the carriage.
As you're putting the needles
through this carriage,
as you're passing the carriage along,
those little round ball bearings are
traveling through these red lines.
And across the very back here,
you see absolutely nothing is going
to happen on this back bed here.
So if the needles are in A position,
they're just going to pass through
and nothing's going to happen.
If the needles travel through this track,
they're going to be pulled out,
the latch is opened with magnets,
the yarn will be positioned in the hook
of the needle, the hook will be
pulled back, and a stitch will form.
Keep this in mind as you are thinking
about the position of the needles and how
you're setting your carriage and how
you're creating stitch patterns.
The third thing that you must know
and understand about this machine,
and actually any machine,
are the controls for paterning.
In this case, it's the side levers.
These side levers are the ones that have
the little dot in a triangle,
and it just has a little lever
that goes back and forth.
When
the lever is in the triangle position,
the needles in working position will pass
through the channel under the carriage,
and they will knit.
Set to the circle,
the needles in the working position will
not pass through the channel,
and they will slip and not knit.
With the Russell lever set to single line
like this, the needles in D
position will not knit.
This is used for partial
knitting or short rows and tuck.
With the lever set to the double
the needles in D position will be forced
through the channel under the carriage,
and they will knit.
You can create almost any stitch pattern
on this LK150 machine that you can create
on other machines, single bed machines.
Tuck, slip, ferrile, lace,
and tarsal plating, weaving,
all of those things can be done.
How?
By manually positioning the needles.
Here Here we go back
to the needle positions again.
On the LK150, in any manual machine,
when you personally position the needles
where they need to be,
and you set those levers where they need
to be, you can create stitch
patterns just like any other machine.
Now, on any automatic patterning machine,
your punch card or your electronics are
going to select the needles for you.
On the LK150, keeping it really simple,
you tell it what needles are going to be
put into work and what needles are
going to be held or talked or slipped.
So yes, the LK150 can do almost anything
that any other machine can do,
but it does have some limitations.
It is a manual machine.
You have to select needles yourself.
Now, you can do hand manipulation,
just like on any other machine.
You can transfer stitches,
you can reform stitches to make
garter stitches, for example.
You can cross cables,
do all those things by hand.
You need to do all those things by hand
on any other machine as well, so you're
not missing out with an LK150 there.
One thing the LK150 never had a ribber,
so you're never going to have a ribber.
If you don't know what a ribber is,
you've got needles on your
needle bed going this way.
If you put a ribber,
it's like adding a second machine.
You've got needles going this way,
so you've got knit and curl stitches.
Stitches to do ribbing, for example,
or any other fancy stitch
that has knit and Pearl stitches.
Now, some people will
call the LK150 a toy.
It is not designed for heavy use.
It is plastic.
We've got these Bell Bed machines
that were made in the '60s, maybe even
earlier, and they're still going strong.
You're not going to wear those babies out.
You can wear out the LK150, so we
always recommend that you use good yarn.
Please don't use the hobby
store or a discount store.
No red heart on the LK150, please,
because you can wear the machine out.
So you need to be careful that way and use
a yarn that's appropriate for the machine.
No hand spun, no thick old
lopey hand-spun for your LK150.
It's only 6.
5 millimeters between those needles.
So take care of the yarn
that you're using.
A
lot of knitters will ask for LK150
knitting patterns,
and I see this quite often online.
You have any patterns
for an LK150 machine?
There's no such thing, really.
It's just, knitting
patterns are just math.
They're just a blueprint.
A knitting pattern is mathematical.
Based on your gage,
it'll tell you cast on X number
of stitches, knit for X number of rows,
decrease every row three times, decrease
every other row four times and bind off.
It's just math, and it's just the same
no matter what machine you're using.
If you want an LK150 pattern,
you're going to have to look
long and hard for it.
And what's going to be the difference
between that and a pattern
for a Brother 970?
Really no different.
I'm going to cast on so many stitches,
I'm going to knit so many rows,
and I'm going to do the decreases.
So So there's really no difference.
And if you need a knitting pattern to tell
you which Russell lever to push or
which side lever to push, shame on you.
You need to learn what those Russell
levers and what those side levers
do on your own so you understand.
Please understand what your machine can
do, and don't rely on someone to tell you,
push the A button or push
the C button or whatever.
It's the same thing with this
pass-up that I'm working on.
It's got AX and BX and CX and DX.
What does that mean?
Tell me what it means.
I've got to understand what's going
on with my machine and not depend on a
pattern to tell me which lever to push.
Figure it out on your own,
you'll be a lot happier.
And you can use hand knitting patterns.
You can use any pattern that give
you decent mathematical instructions.
Now, the LK150 has some accessories.
We're knitters, and we always like to buy
the latest toys to go with our machines.
And there are some toys that you can
purchase and that you can
accumulate for your LK150.
The first one is a second carriage,
and a lot of knitters invest
in a second carriage for their machine.
It makes it a lot easier if you're
knitting multi-colors.
For example, let's see you're
knitting in black and white.
So you have black on this side
in a carriage, and you have white
in the carriage on this side.
You'll knit two rows in the black,
two rows in the white,
two rows in the black,
two rows in the white, without having to
remove the yarn and rethread the carriage.
Really comes in handy if you're
doing a lot of color work.
So a second carriage is
a really good investment.
Once upon a time, there were
ferrile carriages for your machine.
A ferrile carriage will allow you
to put black and white in the same...
A
ferrile carriage It will allow you to put
black and white in the same color
in the same carriage at the same time.
So you can position your needles by hand.
You're still going to have to pull some
needles out, but push your carriage across
one time, and it'll knit black stitches,
white stitches, black stitches, white
stitches with one pass of the carriage.
Now, I go through all that.
Fair-isle carriages are as
rare to find as hens teeth.
Don't you love that expression?
They are very rare and hard to find.
They aren't making them anymore, sadly.
So to do fair oil on an LK150,
you need to do two passes
of the carriage for each row.
You're doing black and white again.
Thread your carriage up with black,
pull some needles out,
knit the black stitches,
free pass, remove the black,
free pass back, put in the white,
pull the other needles out,
knit across, knit the white stitches.
So you've knit one row with two
passes of the carriage.
So ferrile can be a little tedious,
but it's doable, and it's so much fun,
and it's so beautiful when it's done.
You don't need a ferrile carriage.
An intarsia car, a carriage that is
available is the intarja carriage.
Now, again, it's the same idea of being
able to knit multiple colors across a row.
Intarja.
Think about intarja as blocks of color.
So you've got a black
block and a white block.
You would knit that in two
passes of the carriage again.
You could...
So think of Intarja as color blocks,
a black block and a white block.
With an intarsia carriage,
you could do both black and white
in one pass of the carriage.
You would thread up the black,
for example, and then you would
loop or you would
thread up the black, for example,
and then you would lay the white yarn.
Thread up the black, for example,
in the carriage, and then lay the white
yarn across the needles
that you want to knit in white.
Pass the intarsia carriage across once,
and both black and white
stitches will knit.
Very handy for doing that type of work,
an Intarsia Carriage,
and those are available.
Now in In this image here, you can
see something called a needle beetle.
This is a really thrifted, really nifty...
In this image here, you can see
something called a needle beetle.
It's a really nifty little accessory
that is, I think of it as a memorizer.
The way it works is you select the first
eight needles, you do it in groups of...
I like to think of it as the memorizer.
You choose your needles in groups
of eight, so eight stitch multiples.
So let's say I choose every other
needle and pull it out manually.
I then run my needle Beatle across those
eight needles and it memorizes every other
needle and then continues to select every
other needle in that sequence
all the way across the bed.
So again, if you were if you were
knitting every fourth needle out of...
If you took every a fourth needle and put
it into position,
you could memorize
the first eight and then go across the bed
and it repeats that sequence
across the bed.
Needle Beatle is something
that is also for sale.
They're very, very handy if you like to do
pattern work and you don't
have to think as much.
You just remember to position your first
eight multiples, and then it
repeats it across the row.
Another accessory is a garter bar.
A garter Garter bar allows you to
remove stitches from the machine
and put them back on again very easily.
You could do all 150 if you
had a garter bar wide enough.
Now, garter bars for this
machine at the 6.
5 millimeter are also very,
very hard to find.
I won't say anything about hens teeth,
but they are very difficult to find.
Look for a garter bar that's a 6.
5 millimeter, and you'd be able
to remove the stitches from...
You'd be able to remove the stitches
from the bed,
take the knitting off the bed,
turn everything around, put the stitches
back on the bed, and knit another row.
By turning it around, you'll now
have pearl stitches facing you.
Take the knitting off the bed,
turn it around, and knit it again so you
can alternate knit & Pearl stitches
and create some garter stitch,
which would be really tedious,
but for short little bits of garter
stitch, you could do that.
You can I also use a garter
bar for holding stitches.
So they're very handy,
even though they're hard to find.
Another accessory is a patterning device.
The one that's available for this
machine is a KR10 or KR11 11.
These, again, are no longer being made.
They're something you'd have to look for,
but they're not so difficult to find.
The charting device, and I believe
I have a little diagram here.
Here's a charting device.
If you think about it, this little device,
as you push your carriage back and forth,
it increments your row counter.
So on this machine, you attach
the charting device to your row counter.
And as you knit,
the row counter, the CROCounter advances
the paper drawing of your garment,
and you can follow the lines
and do your increases and decreases
without thinking about numbers.
So instead of saying,
decrease one stitch every two rows 10
times, you just decrease as
the little line passes the indicator.
Charting devices are a great tool.
If you can find one, if you're making
garments, they're really, really helpful.
And again, they're something
It's not as easy to find.
Third accessory,
call it an accessory, is software.
Designinit is a piece as such as...
So here's a picture
of the charting device.
The LK150 and Designinit.
Designinit is software
that allows you to do a lot.
It allows you to create garment shapes so
you can create your own knitting patterns.
It allows you to visually
design stitch patterns.
On the screen makes it very
easy to design stitch patterns.
Most people think of designing it
with electronic knitting machines because
one of the features of designing it is
that you can design stitch patterns
and then download them to an
electronic knitting machine.
So the electronic knitting machine then
will select your needles for you based
on what you designed in and design a knit.
Obviously, we're not going
to do that with our LK150.
There's no electronics in our
little plastic machine.
However, you can create stitch patterns
and stitch pattern diagrams that you can
follow to manually pull
and select needles.
Another thing that you can do with design
a knit is create your garment shapes.
So you want to make yourself a sweater
that is set in sleeves with a V- neck,
and it's got a fitted waist, and it's
A-line, and it's got a curved hem.
No problem.
Do it in design a knit,
and then design a knit,
you can use the design in its interactive
knitting as a charting device and follow
the lines and do your shaping.
You need a cable, and There is a little
magnet here that acts as
a tripper for the charting device, the
interactive knitting part of Designinit.
I'll link to the video and some
of the other things I've talked about
here in the description of this video.
So you can create stitch pattern diagrams,
you can create your garments,
you can use the interactive knitting,
all with design a knit and your LK150.
So just because you have a plastic bed
machine, machine doesn't mean
you're limited in what you can do.
As you can see, you can do all the stitch
patterns, you can use software,
you can do all the things you
can do with any other machine.
Here's an example of the interactive
knitting screen in design it.
So you would just follow along.
It tells you exactly which
needles to do your shaping.
We're shaping the top of a sleeve here,
and it tells you exactly
where to do your shaping.
It's saying decrease.
And she actually has a little voice.
She'll say, Decrease one,
left, decrease one right.
Keeps you on track, and you don't have
to think about numbers and keeping track.
This whole time, I keep talking about how
easy it is to learn the LK150 fifty,
and it is easy to learn.
One of the challenges is
to take it step by step.
I can't tell you how many knitters say
to me, I just got my machine last week and
I want to knit my son-in-law a sweater.
Okay, Good for you.
Can you cast on?
How's your knitting?
Do you want to put a stitch pattern in?
Have you increased and decreased?
Do you know how to put stitches and hold?
What about binding off?
I mean, there are so many things to learn
that but not necessarily machine-specific.
So we've created a series of courses
that are machine-specific for your LK150.
And we do tell you, push this lever
and push that lever, unlike patterns.
The LK150 Quick Start introduces you
to all the pieces and parts of your
machine so that you know what they're
used for and what they're called.
We go back to that whole Glossary again.
I don't want you to be looking up,
what does she mean by a latch tool?
Take the LK150 Quick Start,
learn what your latch tool looks like,
and have it handy when you're knitting.
The LK150 Fun Course has to do with what
you can do without any stitch patterns.
It is cables, and increasing,
and decreasing, and short rows,
and all the things that you can do
with your machine from the very beginning.
Once you understand how to cast on and get
some stitches on the machine,
you'll need to take a look at LK150 Fun.
After that, when you're ready,
we want to talk about paterning.
We talked about ferrile and tuck and slip
and intarsia, all those good things.
So that's the next step on your journey.
And then when you get really ambitious
and you've covered all of that,
you might want to start
with a pair of socks on your LK150.
So all four of these courses are
available for you at Net-it Now.
They are sold in a bundle.
They're also included
with a premium membership.
Thank you again for joining me
on this overview of the LK150.
If you have an LK150,
I hope I've inspired you to dive
a little deeper into the possibilities.
You know you can do almost anything
that any other machine can do with your
machine, and I hope I've
inspired you to give it a try.
If you have any questions about an LK150,
or you're thinking about purchasing one or
learning more about how to use one,
please go to learnlk150.
Com.
It's a sister site of Knit It Now, and
we're happy to help you way that we can.
Happy knitting on your
LK150 or any other machine.